ja das kam gerade ganz klar rüber jetzt
mit dieser Pressekonferenz 12 Seiten
über 12 Seiten spricht Deutschland hier
liegen sie die 12 Seiten das ist das
Papier der ampelianer dass sie gerade
auch veröffentlicht haben und da steckt
schon allerhand drin das ist sozusagen
ihre allererste teilweise unkonkrete
teilweise aber auch schon etwas konkrete
Idee für ihre vier Jahre Regierungszeit
für die Zukunft Deutschlands bei uns im
Studio Bild politikchef Jan Schäfer das
Papier hier da steckt einiges drin habe
ich schon gesagt wir wollen über die
Inhalte sprechen aber erstmal über die
zentrale Botschaft offenbar funktioniert
mit der Ampel zumindest noch also wir
haben gerade die Pressekonferenz gesehen
ganz genau die Spitzen der drei Parteien
SPD grün und FDP empfehlen ihren Gremien
jetzt darüber abzustimmen und darüber
positiv abzustimmen über diese 12 Seiten
um dann in Koalitionsverhandlungen in
der nächsten Woche einsteigen zu können
und jetzt schauen wir aber ganz genau
rein jetzt schauen wir inhaltlich rein
in diese 12 Seiten das will die Ampel
kann jetzt eben gerade gesagt man hat
sich auf vieles schon festgelegt
beispielsweise der Mindestlohn der
steigt auf 12 € Olaf Scholz hatte das
bereits im Wahlkampf die ganze Zeit als
sein eines seiner großen Ziele erklärt
konnte sich Jan offenbar hier auch
durchsetzen er konnte sich durchsetzen
ganz genau so wie auch die Grünen beide
Parteien haben immer davon gesprochen
den Mindestlohn auf 12 Euro am liebsten
in einem Schritt anzuheben wir sind
derzeit bei 9,60 € und genau das
passiert jetzt auch und es heißt in
diesem Papier bereits im ersten Jahr das
heißt wir können davon ausgehen 2022
wird der Mindestlohn war noch immer
möglicherweise nicht zum ersten ersten
aber innerhalb der ersten 12 Monate dann
angehoben auf 12 Euro das ist ein
gewaltiger Schritt das sind deutlich
über 20 Prozent lohnaufschlag also das
ist schon ziemlich viel und Kern
wahlversprechend eben von der SPD von
Olaf Scholz das heißt hier schon einmal
Check Haken dran 12 Euro Mindestlohn
kommen und die FDP trägt das mit das hat
Christian Lindner gerade gesagt das muss
die FDP also Kopfschmerzen nochmal Blick
drauf auf diese Tafel denn das sind die
Punkte auf die sich die Ampel Jana bis
hierher geeinigt haben in ihren
Sondierungsgesprächen Punkt Nummer zwei
ja ein Bürgergeld statt Hartz IV was
kann ich mit runter vorstellen außer
dass es netter klingt genau es klingt
netter und das wird sich auch sicherlich
nicht ganz so schnell umsetzen lassen
das ist eine Idee der FDP das sogenannte
liberale Bürgergeld da geht es darum
dass man aus den Hartz IV Empfängern
keine Antragsteller im herkömmlichen
Sinne machen möchte sondern sie eher
animieren möchte einen Job aufzunehmen
und dass man beispielsweise bei dem
liberalen Bürgergeld die Chance bekommt
wenn man nebenbei sich etwas dazu
verdient auch mehr von diesem Extra Lohn
den man hat behalten zu können also
weniger an den Start abgeben muss und
die Idee ist zu sagen Mensch nimm doch
eine Arbeit auf es hilft Dir und da so
aus Hartz IV oder aus der Stütze
rauszuwachsen wieder in ein normales
jobverhältnis lasst uns weiter in dieses
Papier hinein blicken dass man kann es
sagen ja schon etwas über die Zukunft
unseres Landes verrät die Punkte bei
denen man sich jetzt schon einig ist
Deutschland soll schneller und
effektiver werden keine Rentenkürzungen
auch das jetzt gehen wir aber noch
einmal zurück den Klima ganz großes
Thema auch hier hatte man Streit
befürchtet wie wird das bezahlt wie kann
man die Ziele der Grünen erreichen das
ist völlig klar Tempolimits davon muss
man sich verabschieden das hat Robert
Habeck Jan ja auch eben gerade in der
Pressekonferenz gesagt da konnten wir
uns nicht durchsetzen das ist richtig
aber die Grünen sind sonst was den Punkt
angeht und das was man bisher in diesem
sondierungspapier lesen kann eigentlich
sehr gut weggekommen haben sich sehr
stark durchsetzen können es soll unter
anderem eine solardach-pflicht geben bei
Neubauten achtung nicht für Privathäuser
aber zumindest für gewerbliche Häuser
also für Industrieunternehmen oder
generell Unternehmen das zweite ganz
wichtig ist wird darauf hingearbeitet
dass der Kohleausstieg ja beschlossen
vor zwei Jahren 2038 sollen die letzten
Kohlekraftwerke vom Netz gehen um bis zu
8 Jahre vorgezogen wird also auf das
Jahr
2030 das heißt dieser mü Kohlekompromiss
der wird noch mal aufgeschnürt noch mal
aufgemacht genau das Datum ist nicht fix
20 30 das heißt bestenfalls auf 20 30
vorziehen das wird bedeuten dass wir
eigentlich in 9 Jahren dann schon
komplett aus der Kohle aussteigen das
halte ich für einen wirklich harten
harten und großen Brocken wir wissen
dass die Kohle im ersten Halbjahr dieses
Jahres 27 Prozent zum gesamten Strommix
beigetragen also mehr als ein Viertel
und dieses mehr als ein Viertel das will
man also innerhalb der nächsten neun
Jahre dann komplett ersetzen das ist
eine sehr sehr sehr große
Herausforderung ich bin nicht sicher und
würde eher sagen das klappt nicht und
Solarzellen Pflicht du hast es gesagt
für alle gewerblichen Neubauten heißt
auf jedem Supermarkt beispielsweise
müssen künftig Solarzellen sein die eben
die Sonnenenergie aufnehmen und
umwandeln wir schauen weiter rein in die
wichtigsten Punkte dieser 12 Seiten über
die ab heute Deutschland spricht und
Deutschland diskutiert wir haben
gesprochen über Klimaschutz und sprechen
natürlich auch über die andere Kohle
über Steuererhöhung Ja oder Nein in den
Papier steht drin ganz klar nein die
kommen nicht Jan ja da konnte sich die
FDP zumindest teilweise durchsetzen die
ja im Wahlkampf gesagt hat keine
Steuererhöhungen und auch keine neuen
Steuern beides konnte sie durchsetzen
zum Beispiel gegen den Wunsch der SPD
aber auch der Grünen dir für eine neue
Vermögenssteuer gekämpft haben da heißt
es ganz klar es gibt keine neuen Steuern
und keine Steuererhöhungen aber das
wollte die FDP auch und da musste sie
die Waffen strecken sie wollte den
Solidaritätszuschlag abschaffen komplett
für alle das wird jetzt nicht passieren
in Klammern man hofft darauf dass das
Bundesverfassungsgericht im nächsten
Jahr den Soli sowieso kippen wird aber
es ist nicht mehr Teil des
sondierungspapiers und wird damit auch
nicht Teil des Koalitionsvertrages
werden Olaf Scholz sagte immer in der
Pressekonferenz es wird das größte
industrielle Modernisierungsprojekt das
Deutschland wahrscheinlich seit über 100
Jahren durchgeführt hat grund genug noch
mal detailliert in diese 12 Seiten
reinzuschauen zu schauen was die Ampel
vor hat zwölf Seiten man konnte sich auf
viele Themen einigen man musste einige
Kompromisse auch eingehen die wir hier
bereits erläutert haben dass uns weiter
detailliert in dieses Papier schauen
volle Kraft auf Digitalisierung heißt es
unter anderem darin auch weitere Themen
weitere Punkte wurden abgehakt am Anfang
des Papiers wurde ganz klar gesagt
natürlich konnten wir nicht alle Punkte
beschreiben auch auf der Pressekonferenz
wurde noch mal deutlich gemacht es wird
es gibt weitere Punkte es gibt weiter
auch noch Stoff für Diskussionen die
Rente zum Beispiel auf die müssen wir
gucken hier steht ja drauf auf der Tafel
jetzt geht es ein bisschen schnell aber
steht drin keine Rentenkürzung dass die
positive Nachricht vor allen Dingen der
SPD war dieses Thema ja ganz wichtig die
Rentenkürzung standen allerdings auch
gar nicht an das war bisher noch gar
nicht groß in der Diskussion aber
spannend wird wenn wir über die
gesetzliche Rente sprechen ja da gibt es
das war der FDP besonders wichtig eine
ganz besondere Neuerung richtig Rente
ist ein entscheidender Faktor weil er
ein großer Kostenfaktor ist im
Bundeshaushalt über 100 Milliarden also
über 100 Milliarden fließen mittlerweile
jedes Jahr aus dem Bundeshaushalt in die
Rentenkasse und es gibt zwei Punkte die
entscheidend dabei sind es soll diese
sogenannte Haltlinie also das
Rentenniveau soll auch nicht weiter
sinken das wollten grün und SPD beachten
40 Prozent verschreiben das bleibt so
und ganz wichtig es soll in den nächsten
vier Jahren nicht über einen späteres
Renteneintrittsalter debattiert werden
das heißt die Rente mit 67 bleibt die
wird nicht zur Rente mit 68 oder 69 oder
70 die bleibt auch das wichtig bedeutet
aber dass die Rente natürlich weiter
extremer Kostenfaktor ist noch teurer
werden wird ein in einem Punkt konnte
sich die FDP durchsetzen und zwar beim
Thema
Finanzierung es wird künftig die Rente
nicht nur aus den Beiträgen der
Arbeitnehmer bezahlt werden und aus dem
steuersättel sondern es wird sowas geben
wie ein extra Rentenkonto ein
Kapitalstock der sonst zunächst erstmal
zehn Milliarden Euro reinfließen das ist
jetzt nicht sehr viel wenn man überlegt
dass die Rentenzahlung pro Jahr bei über
300 Milliarden liegen aber ganz klar ist
da ist ein erster Punkt ein erster
Baustein dass man auch beispielsweise
von Entwicklung an Aktienmärkten
profitieren möchte und nicht nur von dem
was die Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer erarbeiten also der Staat
zahlt von unseren Renten einbeiträgen
und für unsere künftigen Renten ein in
einen Fonds legt das Geld an in Aktien
beispielsweise das kann zu einer
Dividende führen das kann aber auch zu
Verlusten führen theoretisch vollkommen
richtig jetzt könnte ich mir vorstellen
dass so angelegt wird gibt genug Modelle
dass man das eingezahlte Geld nicht
verlieren kann aber muss ich das
vorstellen dass man wie in einem
privaten Rentenfonds dann einzahlt das
macht der Staat jetzt und er hofft dass
dieses dieser kleine Betrag von 10
Milliarden immer stärker anwächst also
dass man künftig aus auch daraus
Rentenerhöhung beispielsweise
finanzieren kann das ist die Idee die
dahinter steckt jetzt lass uns auf die
jungen Menschen blicken denn auch für
die stehen Nachrichten in diesem Papier
junge die vor allem auch die FDP gewählt
haben und die jetzt bei der nächsten
Wahl dann deutlich früher wählen sollen
sie sollen wählen künftig ab 16 und zwar
nicht nur auf kommunaler Ebene das ist
ja bereits heute möglich sondern eben
auch auf Bundesebene und auch für die
Europawahl das ist das was im
sondierungspapier steht wir sehen gerade
den Kanzler ja genau
ab an der Berliner Messe das ist heute
das muss mir auch mal auf ihn persönlich
noch mal fokussieren das ist der nächste
Schritt heute in seine Kanzlerschaft
also ein historischer Moment für ihn er
hat das gerade erledigt den nächsten
Haken sozusagen dran gemacht an den Bau
seiner künftigen Koalition wichtiger
Schritt in Richtung seiner Kanzlerschaft
aber zurück zu diesem Thema vor allen
Dingen für alle jungen Menschen auch
Jugendliche in Deutschland wichtig das
Wahlalter soll gesenkt werden so hast du
es gerade gemacht gesagt Jan auch für
bei den Bundestagswahlen genau bei der
Bundestagswahl so steht's zumindest im
sondierungspapier jetzt drin die
Bundestagswahlen sollen künftig oder 16
Jahre sollen künftig die Chance haben
bei der Bundestagswahl auch mit zu
wählen das ist bisher erst ab 18 möglich
und die gleiche Möglichkeit auch geben
bei den Europawahlen also für jüngere
Menschen die noch nicht erwachsen sind
bieten sich hier durchaus Scheiße
dran kann man das Durchsetzen als Ampel
wohl nein das braucht auch die
Zustimmung von cdu/csu selbst wenn sie
an der Bundesregierung nicht mehr
beteiligt sind das braucht eine zwei
Drittel Mehrheit dann solch eine
Änderungen am Wahlrecht Richtung richtig
genau das heißt das wird dürfte schwer
werden aber so ein sondierungspapier ist
ja auch gemacht um jetzt in der eigenen
Basis für Zustimmung zu sorgen die
Grünen müssen am Sonntag bei einem
kleinen Länderrat sich die Zustimmung
und das das Grün sozusagen holen das
okay damit sie in
Koalitionsverhandlungen einsteigen
können die FDP will das am Montag machen
da sollen der Vorstand zusammen mit der
Fraktion darüber beraten und ebenfalls
grünes Licht geben die SPD will das mit
ihren Vorstandsmitgliedern auch
besprechen also jetzt sind die parteimit
die da gefragt bzw die Delegierten um
grünes Licht zu geben dass man in den
nächsten Schritt gehen kann in die
richtigen harten Koalitionsverhandlungen
12 Seiten 12 wichtige Seiten ja welche
Punkte sind noch wichtig worauf konnte
man sich einigen und konntest du auch
jetzt eben anhand dieser Pressekonferenz
auch schon Punkte bemerken wo man sagen
könnte jetzt mit Blick auf die
Koalitionsverhandlungen auf die man sich
geeinigt hat da könnte es dann
vielleicht doch noch einmal Knirschen
oder Scholz der hat sich ja jetzt auch
optimistisch gezeigt und auch im Papier
heißt es ja wir sind davon überzeugt
dass wir einen ambitionierten und
tragfähigen Koalitionsvertrag schließen
können also dass das Resümee der drei
Parteien zu diesem Papier ja ein
wichtiger Punkt weil du gerade nämlich
danach fragtest da geht es um das Thema
wohnen da geht es um das Thema Bauen das
war für Olaf Scholz extrem wichtig im
Wahlkampf für die Grünen auch und da hat
man sich geeinigt dass man pro Jahr
400.000 neue Wohnungen bauen möchte
100.000 davon staatlich auch richtig
gefördert um auch die Mieten unter die
Situation auf den Mietmarkt zu
entspannen am Ende und du fragtest was
steht noch alles drin der wohnungspunkt
ist ein wichtiger etwas was nicht drin
steht was am Ende aber extrem wichtig
ist die Frage ja wie soll das am Ende
alles finanziert werden und ich glaube
das ist ein Punkt über um den geht jetzt
in den Koalitionsverhandlungen das liest
sich jetzt alles sehr sehr schön aber es
ist der größte Brocken die Frage wer
bezahlt und deswegen der nächste
Finanzminister der wird den härtesten
Job von allen Ministern im Kabinett
haben weil der derjenige sein wird der
die Schuldenbremse dann auch wieder
Einheiten muss und er muss das alles
finanzieren und da wird es die großen
Auseinandersetzungen in den nächsten
Wochen geben um die Frage was können wir
eigentlich durchsetzen was können wir
schnell durchsetzen und was können wir
vielleicht doch gar nicht finanzieren
und wer den Job kriegen soll auch
darüber wurde noch nicht gesprochen das
war gerade interessanter Moment auch die
Nachfrage wurde ja gestellt und das
machte dann Christian Lindner kurz ganz
verlegen also per Personalfragen
bisher noch nicht besprochen ist noch zu
früh dafür danke Bild Politik seit Jan
Schäfer geben
[Musik]